welcome to up all night thank you thank
you
no guys seriously please thank you hey
today we're discussing my three favorite
ways to prank noobs ooh sexy there's a
lot of good ones okay my first one is a
package deal when they're not looking
hold down the Apple option control keys
and press the number 8
it'll invert their colors that will
freak them out for an added bonus little
cherry on top
hold down the same 3 keys and press
period to alter the contrast if they're
using a PC hold down the left Alt +
Shift keys and press print screen' say
yes and bam oh that's neat or try this
javascript copy code number 1 in this
video's description and paste it into
your browser's URL bar and press Enter
ooh my breeding I can't everything be
that easy well you are you can also
impress fail people by tricking them
into thinking you hacked websites like
YouTube copy code number 2 and paste it
in your address bar and hit enter all
right I'm gonna change this over here
I'll make that that mm-hmm and then I'll
move him over here and how about instead
of that this mmm JavaScript
I'm totally gonna use this on my stupid
gamer ex-boyfriend wait you dated a
gamer it was actually pretty incredible
he gave my xbox a 360 then a friend came
over and we all did a PlayStation 3 she
didn't know D ass and then I booted his
big throbbing let me guess you were like
we don't be gross by the way why do they
use dolls instead of real people for
this show well because you can do things
with us that would never happen in real
life for instance watch this did you
know that I was the first member of my
guild to achieve the two set bonus for
tier 9 gear I want you see up all night
was brought to you by Tetris Super Mario
Bros and they all knew we J thanks for
watching guys be sure to subscribe to
Vsauce for more if any of you out there
make your own videos be sure to like us
on Facebook and submit them there maybe
we'll even give you a shout out get on
that Facebook
you